à une chose nécessaire.
En parlant d'un stimulateur cardiaque en tant que prothèse,
vous parlez de quelque chose n'étant pas juste « la jambe que je n'ai plus »,
plutôt « sans cela, je peux mourir ».
A ce point, une prothèse devient une relation symbiotique
avec le corps humain.
Quatre des personnes les plus intelligentes que je connaisse,
Ey Boyden, Hugh Herr, Joe Jacobson, Bob Lander --
travaillent dans un centre de bionique extrême.
Ce qui est intéressant dans ce que vous voyez
est que ces prothèses ont été intégrées dans l'os,
dans la peau,
dans le muscle.
Et, d'un autre côté,
Ed réfléchit à comment connecter le cerveau
en utilisant de la lumière ou d'autres mécanismes
directement à des choses telles que ces prothèses.
Si vous parvenez à faire ça,
vous commencerez à changer des aspects fondamentaux de l'humanité.
Votre rapidité de réaction dépend du diamètre d'un nerf.
Bien sûr, si vos nerfs sont externes ou prosthétiques,
munis de lumière ou de métal liquide,
vous pouvez augmenter ce diamètre,
voire, théoriquement, l'augmenter jusqu'au point où,
en voyant le flash lumineux, vous pourriez éviter une balle.
Voilà l'ordre de grandeur des changements dont nous parlons.
C'est un quatrième niveau dans la prosthétique.
Voici des appareils auditifs Phonak
et ils sont si intéressants
car ils franchisent la limite des prothèses comme quelque chose
pour les « handicapés »
et qu'elles deviennent quelque chose que quelqu'un de « normal »
pourrait vouloir
car ce que fait cette prothèse est très intéressant,
elle vous aide à entendre
et de concentrer votre ouïe
afin de pouvoir entendre la conversation là-bas.
Vous pouvez avoir une super-ouïe,
une ouïe à 360 degrés, un bruit blanc,
vous pouvez enregistrer et y brancher un téléphone.
Cela sert d'aide auditive et de téléphone.
A ce point-là, quelqu'un pourrait volontairement vouloir d'une prothèse.
Tous ces milliers de morceaux vaguement connectés
se réunissent
et il est temps de poser la question :
comment voulons-nous faire évoluer les humains au cours du prochain siècle ?
Nous nous tournons alors vers un grand philosophe
qui était un homme très intelligent bien que fan des Yankee.
(Rires)
Yogi Berra disait qu'il est difficile de faire des prévisions,
surtout concernant le futur.
(Rires)
Donc au lieu de faire une prédiction sur le futur,
prenons ce qu'il se passe maintenant avec des gens comme Tony Atala,
qui re-conçoit une trentaine d'organes.
Peut-être que la prothèse ultime n'est pas externe ni en titane,
peut-être que c'est de prendre son propre code génétique,
refaire ses propres membres
car c'est beaucoup plus efficace que tout type de prothèse.
Mais, tant qu'à y être, prenez le travail de Craig Venter et Ham Smith.
Une des choses qu'ils font,
c'est essayer de comprendre comment reprogrammer des cellules.
Si vous savez faire cela,
vous pouvez changer les cellules dans ces organes.
Et si vous pouvez faire cela,
ces organes pourraient résister aux radiations,
absorber plus d'oxygène,
être plus efficaces
pour filtrer ce que vous ne voulez pas dans votre corps.
Les dernières semaines, les médias ont parlé de George Church
car il a parlé de prendre une de ces cellules reprogrammables
et d'insérer un génome humain entier
dans cette cellule.
Une fois que vous insérez un génome humain entier dans une cellule,
vous commencez à poser la question :
voudriez-vous améliorer une partie de ce génome ?
Voulez-vous améliorer un corps humain ?
Comment voudriez-vous améliorer un corps humain ?
Quand est-il éthique et quand n'est-il pas éthique
d'améliorer un corps humain ?
Tout à coup,
nous avons un plateau d'échec mutlidimensionnel
où nous pouvons changer la génétique humaine en utilisant un virus
pour attaquer le SIDA, par exemple,
ou, via la thérapie génétique, changer le code génétique
pour se débarrasser de maladies héréditaires
ou changer l'environnement
et changer l'expression de ces gènes dans l'épigénome
et le passer aux futures générations.
Tout à coup, ce n'est pas qu'un seul morceau,
ce sont plein de petits morceaux
et vous pouvez en prendre des portions
jusqu'à ce que, en réunissant ces portions,
vous arriviez à quelque chose de très différent.
Cela fait très peur à beaucoup de monde.
Cela semble effrayant et il y a des risques.
Pourquoi voudrions-nous faire ce genre de choses ?
Pourquoi voudrions-nous fondamentalement altérer le corps humain ?
Une partie de la réponse
est donnée par Lord Rees,
un astronome royal de Grande-Bretagne.
Il dit souvent que l'univers est entièrement malveillant.
Qu'est-ce que cela signifie ?
Si vous choisissez aléatoirement un de vos corps,
le lâchez n'importe où dans l'univers,
le lâchez dans l'espace, vous mourrez ;
sur le soleil, vous mourrez ;
à la surface de Mercure, vous mourrez ;
près d'une supernova, vous mourrez.
Malheureusement, cela n'est vrai qu'à 80%.
Un grand physicien a dit
qu'il y avait, en amont, des tourbillons de biologie
qui créent l'ordre dans ce torrent rapide de l'entropie.
Alors que l'univers dissipe de l'énergie,
il y a, en amont, des tourbillons créant l'ordre biologique.
Le problème des tourbillons est qu'ils ont tendance à disparaître.
Ils bougent, se déplacent dans les rivières.
Quand un tourbillon se déplace,
quand la Terre devient une boule de neige, quand elle devient très chaude,
quand elle est frappée par un astéroïde, quand il y a des super-volcans,
quand il y a des éruptions solaires,
quand il y a des événements pouvant mener à une extinction
tels que l'élection à venir --
(Rires)
tout à coup, il peut y avoir des extinctions périodiques.
Cela s'est produit cinq fois sur Terre
et il est donc très probable
que l'espèce humaine sur Terre finisse par s'éteindre.
Pas la semaine prochaine,
pas le mois prochain,
peut-être en novembre mais peut-être dans 10 000 ans.
Alors que vous réfléchissez aux conséquences de cela,
si vous croyez que les extinctions sont communes, naturelles,
normales et se produisant périodiquement,
la diversification de notre espèce devient un impératif moral.
Cela devient un impératif moral
car il va être très difficile de vivre sur Mars
si nous ne modifions pas fondamentalement le corps humain.
N'est-ce pas ?
Vous passez d'une cellule,
la réunion de maman et papa en une cellule,
à une cascade de 10 000 milliards de cellules.
Nous ignorons si, en changeant substantiellement la gravité,
la même chose permettra de créer votre corps.
Nous ignorons si, comme actuellement, en exposant nos corps
à beaucoup de radiations, nous mourrons.
En y réfléchissant, nous devons reconcevoir les choses
pour arriver sur Mars.
Oublions les lunes de Neptune ou Jupiter.
Et pour reprendre ce que Nikolai Kardashev a dit :
voyons la vie à plusieurs échelles.
La civilisation de type I
est une civilisation qui commence à altérer son apparence.
Nous le faisons depuis des milliers d'années.
Il y a la plastie du ventre et ceci et cela.
Vous altérez votre apparence et on me dit
que toutes ces altérations n'ont pas de forcément de cause médicale.
(Rires)
Cela semble étrange.
Une civilisation de type II est différente.
Une civilisation de type II altère des aspects fondamentaux du corps.
Vous injectez des hormones de croissance, la personne grandit,
ou vous injectez x et la personne est plus rapide ou perd du métabolisme
ou fait toute une série de choses,
mais vous altérez les fonctions de façon fondamentale.
Pour devenir une civilisation intra-solaire,
nous devrons créer une civilisation de type III
et cela est très différent de ce que nous avons.
Épissez peut-être Deinococcus radiodurans
afin que les cellules puissent se ré-épisser
après une forte exposition à des radiations.
On respirera peut-être en ayant l'oxygène directement dans le sang
et non par les poumons.
Mais nous parlons de re-conceptions radicales
et, une chose intéressante s'étant produite les dix dernières années,
est que nous avons découvert plein de planètes.
Peut-être que certaines ressemblent à la Terre.
Le problème est que, si nous voulons arriver sur ces planètes,
les objets humains les plus rapides --
Juno, Voyager et les autres --
prennent des dizaines de milliers d'années
pour aller d'ici au système solaire voisin.
Si vous voulez commencer à explorer des plages ailleurs
ou voir deux soleils se coucher,
vous parlez de quelque chose de vraiment très différent
car vous devez changer l'échelle du temps et le corps humain
et les rendre méconnaissables.
C'est une civilisation de type IV.
Nous ne pouvons pas imaginer ce à quoi cela ressemblerait
mais nous avons un premier aperçu
des instruments qui pourraient nous amener si loin.
Je vais vous donner deux exemples.
Voici le merveilleux Floyd Romesberg.
Une des choses que Floyd fait
est qu'il joue avec la chimie fondamentale de la vie.
Sur cette planète, tout est composé de ATCG : les quatre lettres de l'ADN.
Toutes les bactéries, les plantes, les animaux, les humains, les vaches,
tout le reste.
Ce que Floyd a fait, c'est de modifier deux de ces lettres de base
pour passer à ATXY.
Cela signifie que nous avons un système parallèle pour créer la vie,
faire des bébés, se reproduire, évoluer
et il ne s'appareille pas avec la majorité des choses
voire rien sur Terre.
Les plantes seraient peut-être immunisées contre les bactéries et les virus.
Pourquoi est-ce si intéressant ?
Cela signifie que nous ne sommes pas la solution unique.
Cela signifie que l'on peut créer des chimies alternatives à la nôtre
qui pourraient être des chimies adaptables sur une planète très différente
et créer la vie et l'hérédité.
La deuxième expérience,
ou la deuxième implication de cette expérience,
que vous tous, toute vie est basée sur 20 acides aminés.
Si vous ne substituez pas deux acides aminés,
si vous ne dites pas « ATXY » mais « ATCG + XY »,
vous passez de 20 composants à 172 composants
et, tout à coup, vous avez 172 composants d'acides aminés
pour créer différentes formes de vie.
La seconde expérience à laquelle penser est très étrange
et a eu lieu en Chine.
Ce gars a transplanté des centaines de têtes de souris.
N'est-ce pas ?
Pourquoi est-ce une expérience intéressante ?
Pensez à la transplantation cardiaque.
Avant, on avait l'habitude de faire venir la femme ou la fille du donneur
pour que le receveur puisse dire aux docteurs
s'il reconnaissait ou aimait cette personne,
s'il ressentait quelque chose pour elle.
Aujourd'hui, nous en rions
car nous savons que le cœur est un muscle
mais, durant des centaines ou des dizaines de milliers d'années,
nous « donnions », « prenions » ou « brisions » des cœurs.
C'étaient les émotions
et nous pensions que les émotions étaient transplantées avec le cœur.
Non.
Qu'en est-il du cerveau ?
Cette expérience a deux résultats possibles.
Si vous obtenez une souris
qui est fonctionnelle,
vous pouvez voir
si le nouveau cerveau est une ardoise vierge.
Cela a des implications.
La deuxième option :
la souris reconnaît Minnie.
La souris se souvient de quoi elle a peur,
comment se déplacer dans un labyrinthe
et, si c'est vrai,
vous pouvez transplanter la mémoire et la conscience.
La question intéressante est alors :
si vous pouvez transplanter cela, le seul mécanisme d'entrée-sortie
est-il ceci là-haut ?
Ou pourrions-nous transplanter la conscience dans une chose
qui soit très différente, qui subsisterait dans l'espace
ou durant des dizaines de milliers d'années,
qui serait un corps re-conçu
qui contiendrait la conscience pendant très, très longtemps ?
Revenons à la première question :
pourquoi ferions-nous cela ?
Je vais vous le dire.
Car c'est le selfie ultime.
(Rires)
Il est pris à 10 milliards de kilomètres de distance,
et voici la Terre.
Nous voici, nous tous.
Si cette petite chose disparaît, l'humanité disparaît.
Vous voulez altérer le corps humain
car vous voulez finir par prendre une photo disant :
« C'est nous, c'est nous,
et c'est nous »,
car c'est ainsi que l'humanité survivra à l'extinction à long terme.
C'est pourquoi il s'avère
qu'il n'est pas éthique de ne pas faire évoluer le corps humain,
même si cela est effrayant, même si cela est un défi
mais cela nous permettra d'explorer, de vivre
et d'atteindre des endroits inimaginables aujourd'hui
mais pas pour nos arrières-arrières- arrières-arrières-arrières-petits-enfants.
Merci beaucoup.
(Applaudissements)